in 1941 Hungary entered the war Jewish
boys some relatives and friends were
serving in labor but I yawns where they
suffered more from their officers than
from the enemy yet slowly the map on the
wall began finally to smile at us the
Battle of Stalingrad and Roma's defeat
has changed our mood whereas hope in the
end of the war became less and less
vague Hungarian voice was in the army
and in the labor but iron suffered
terrible losses entirely in vain was
morning and hope characterized our daily
life it will be soon over we believed we
hoped yet it was not over
in 1919 44 the Germans occupied Hungary
I immediately know this is my death
sentence only the time of execution was
not yet shattered as a 14 15 year-old
girl without money that could have
bought us false papers I could rely only
on my instincts my father was arrested
in April by the Gestapo because of his
participation in the refugee help group
the Gestapo extradite attempt to the
Hungarian authorities who on their part
put him as a Jew immediately into an
internment camp which was deported in
June 1944 to Auschwitz I never forget
the day when my mother and myself waited
for all elevators stopping at a floor
hours and hours with the fading hope
that perhaps my father will still arrive
he never did when the Hungarian Nazis
the Arrow Cross Party came to power the
route to Auschwitz that was in October
October 44 the route to Auschwitz and to
the gas chambers was already blocked
Mossberg that became less
institutionalized more pogrom like more
personal arrow CrossFit they will
Hungarian Nazis Arrow Cross people were
trigger-happy they showed Jews where
they found them I was taken also with
many others to the shore of that Danube
where they shot us into the river yet
they stopped shooting when our house
would have been the next I concentrated
on the river and decided to jump and try
to escape by swimming in the icy water I
was not afraid not thinking of death but
on swimming I never knew why the Arrow
Cross group stopped murdering us at that
time I should have been killed
it was an accident that I was not these
I never forgot they create in me the
fear of death forever I said that the
beginning of this talk that I speak as a
witness of history a witness of the
history of the 20th century can one
learn something from history
Hagar said once upon a time that only
one thing can be learned from history
namely that nothing can be learned from
history the same can be said about the
life story of a witness Helga was almost
right yet in my view not entirely right
even if one cannot learn the answers one
can learn diagnosis and to ask certain
questions let me know begin with
diagnosis let's turn to the second part
of my talk diagnosis now it's not with
the world the world was always a
dangerous place
and it remained a dangerous place all
promises to the contrary proved to be
lies and empty illusions either lives or
empty illusions it was indeed the most
supreme arrogance to believe that our
times are the exception from all times
that we have arrived finally to the
historical stage but eternal peace
eternal freedom will set roots on the
whole globe and we shall arrive to the
promised land on earth arrogance is
always punished with despair or
arrogance was not just once punished by
disillusionment and despair so what does
it mean to save the world first but do
we mean by world when asking this
question simply the time entered space
into which we were thrown into the world
by accident of birth the place and the
time when we are going to live and where
we are going to die to save the world
may mean to save a void this world the
world into which were we were born and
where we are going to die this word can
be saved from what from self-destruction
and from destroying others the actual
radius that is the place and the time
one can reach with one's action that's
actual radius is different from
different people and different times and
different places one can save something
if one can do something for it one can
save the world
even metaphorically only if the world
this world stands for places for
impending dangers one has not just
information about from books television
or the internet but our
practically within average we can reach
them they can act for them or we can act
against them the second what does it
mean to save and to save from that
saving the world requires first self
liberation from self-incurred
socio-political blindness
they're always dangers because the world
is also always a dangerous place they're
always dangerous sometimes mortal
dangers get recognized only by few whose
voices are not heard sometimes even
ridiculed or silenced
Cassandra remains the mother what makes
people that is us blind fanaticism
credulity boredom ambition fear and hope
by reciting the story of my life I spoke
about the catastrophes of the 20th
century all of them could have been
prevented without exception
none of us believes anymore in Hagar's
dictum that if we look at the world
rationally it will look back at us also
rationally still if you look at the word
rationally that is without hope and
without fear will not act we will not
act irresponsibly taking into
consideration the foreseeable
consequence of our action and as good
citizens discussing them with one
another
to find out how to avoid the most
dangerous choice to repeat not guided by
blind fear of by blind hope even if an
can fear and certainly can oh the world
will never be saved by humans for the
power of saving the attribute to God yet
the metaphor about saving the world can
still serve to
quad [ __ ] as an idea of reason the
metaphor namely suggests the task to
save ourselves from ourselves from
utopias of desire from others of the
perfect set from the image of man
created apocalypse from disappointment
from the sense of being betrayed from
fatigue from cynicism to sum up from
nihilism by taking up the burden of
responsibility good faith and in civic
courage thank you
[Applause]